churros the delectable deep-fried pastry
gooey and soft on the inside with ridges
on the outside that gather pockets of
cinnamon and sugar and help give it that
classic crunch
today we'll show you how to make tasty's
ultimate churro recipe
so who created the churros anyway great
question we don't know the origin of the
churro is heavily debated some say it
originated from spanish shepherds as an
on-the-go replacement for bread it said
that the iconic curled shape was made to
resemble that of a sheep's horn but
another recipe was discovered in ancient
rome for a flower and water fritter that
had strong similarities to the modern
day churro as well there's even a theory
that portuguese sailors brought back
yotiau a similar pastry from china to
portugal and spread into spain
though we can't say for sure where the
first variation of the churro originated
we can tell you that today we're going
to be making our favorite recipe for
churros regardless of its past every
churro starts with a pad a shoe or a
choux pastry which is just a mixture of
flour eggs butter sugar salt milk and
water it's the same dough used for
desserts like cream puffs and eclairs
we'll start with our wet ingredients
we tested a few different water and milk
ratios and found that the half milk half
water ratio helps the dough retain the
right amount of moisture while giving it
the best flavor we'll add our liquids to
a saucepan along with some sugar salt
butter and vanilla bean you can use
vanilla extract if that's what you have
on hand but since we're making the
ultimate churros we want to pack in as
much vanilla flavor as possible it'll
also give us a beautiful speckled dough
once that comes to a boil we'll remove
the vanilla bean and then add in the
flour reduce the heat to medium-low and
stir with a wooden spoon until the
mixture forms a ball and no longer
sticks to the pan about five minutes
you'll know the flour is cooked when it
starts to pull away from the pan leaving
no residue on the sides or bottom this
should take about five minutes
now for the eggs we tested a variety of
egg combinations and we found that two
eggs made the inside of the churro too
gummy but four eggs made it too airy and
spongy so three whole eggs was the
winner not too fluffy not too dense just
right we'll transfer our dough to a bowl
and let it cool for about five minutes
if it's too hot during this step you
might end up with bits of scrambled eggs
in your dough and we definitely don't
want that let's talk about mixing
utensils we found that using a stand
mixer with a paddle attachment is the
best way to mix the dough if you don't
have a stand mixer using a wooden spoon
works great it'll keep the dough at a
constant temperature it's just a little
more work and we here at tasty are all
about simplicity
a metal whisk or an electric hand mixer
will transfer too much heat to the dough
or it could whip too much air into your
dough
excellent now that our dough is cooled
down let's add the eggs one at a time
making sure to completely mix one egg in
before adding the next it's gonna look
really separated and broken but it'll
come together the finished dough should
be gracefully falling from the bottle it
shouldn't plop off it should look like a
thick custard
let's move on to piping there are two
main ways to pipe your churros you can
pipe them by hand using a piping bag
with a star tip or use a churro maker we
tested both ways and found that the chow
maker didn't make a huge difference in
ease or efficiency but it does change
the shape so if you have a churro maker
on hand feel free to use it but hand
piping is totally fine too
we'll be using a star tip to pipe our
churros not only is it the most
traditional but the iconic star shape
increases the surface area which allows
for a bigger crunch and also makes for a
sturdier churro pro tip let the dough
rest for 5 minutes before piping this
will allow the dough to set up a little
and make piping easier
we also experimented with a few other
methods of resting chilling and freezing
the frozen churros brought the
temperature of the oil down and didn't
get as crispy plus you run the risk of
browning on the outside without cooking
it all the way through while chilling in
the fridge made the dough too sticky to
get off the plate we achieved the best
results piping it straight into the oil
now it wouldn't be churros without a
sweet coating you can go crazy with your
churro toppings but for rsp we've
decided to stick to the traditional
cinnamon sugar coating we're using
ceylon cinnamon ceylon cinnamon is
brighter and has more of a floral taste
wacasia is more common and a little more
subtle a good rule of thumb is to add
one teaspoon of cinnamon to every half
cup of sugar
we're using good old granulated sugar
here the small granules stick to the
churros nicely and fit better into all
those delicious nooks and crannies now
it's time to cook our churros our method
of choice is deep frying we found that
it's the only way to really get that
classic crispy exterior and soft center
you just won't get the same results in
an air fryer or the oven the best
temperature to fry your churros is 350
degrees fahrenheit this will ensure your
churros are fully cooked through with
the perfect crispy outside frying at too
high of a temperature could again leave
you with a burnt outside and a raw
center
you can totally stop here and enjoy your
well-deserved churros but we're going to
amp things up a little bit with a spicy
chocolate dipping sauce we're going to
start with the base of the sauce which
is our classic ganache
first we'll heat up our cream and then
add in our cayenne and cinnamon we're
using semi-sweet chocolate chips so our
dip has a little bitterness which will
blend really well with our sweet
cinnamon sugar coating
now for the sweetest part
serving them up
pairing our golden hot churros with our
spicy chocolate dipping sauce makes for
the ultimate combo the perfect crispy
outside and soft pillowy inside tray
our churros are finally ready to eat so
let's give them a taste
yum
one bite of these churros will have you
sang oh yes
[Music]
you